madame la présidente cheriel mesdames et
messieurs les ministres Messieurs les
Présidents chers Sylvain chers François
mesdames et messieurs les députés et
sénateurs mes chers amis
il y a deux choses que j'aime
particulièrement dans les rentrées la
première ce sont les retrouvailles
pendant cette première année on peut le
dire nous nous sommes pas beaucoup
quittés
nous avons gardé le contact pendant
l'été mais je suis très heureuse que
l'on se retrouve tous ensemble
malgré les difficultés malgré la dureté
des débats j'ai hâte de reprendre le
travail parlementaire avec vous
la deuxième chose précieuse dans les
rentrées c'est qu'elles sont l'occasion
de revenir un instant sur le passé et de
préparer l'avenir
alors d'abord disons-le
que de chemin parcourus en un an
rappelons-nous aux sortir des élections
législatives les commentateurs
prédisaient le blocage et les
oppositions étaient bien décidées à nous
l'imposer
il pensait que ce quinquennat serait
celui de l'immobilisme et du renoncement
en un an nous avons prouvé qu'il était
celui de l'action et du courage
[Applaudissements]
car oui il a fallu du courage pour
affronter les hurlements et les injures
dans l'émission mais vous avez tenu et
vous avez gardé votre calme et votre
détermination
pas toujours
[Applaudissements]
oui
oui il a fallu du courage pour changer
nos méthodes proposer des compromis à
toutes les oppositions de l'arc
républicain mais nous l'avons fait nous
avons construit des majorités sont
toujours nous reposer sur les mêmes
forces politiques
c'est ce qu'attendait les Français que
nous construisions avec les oppositions
que nous avons
et oui il a fallu du courage pour garder
le cap des réformes même les plus
difficiles
mais nous n'avons pas cédé et nous avons
réussi à faire passer des textes
importants au service des Français pour
le pouvoir d'achat pour la sécurité pour
la transition écologique pour le plein
emploi en un an de travail près de 50
textes ont été adoptés c'est un bilan
dont nous n'avons pas à rougir n'hésitez
pas à le marteler
ce bilan c'est le nôtre ce bilan c'est
le vôtre il y a le rappeler parmi les
textes adoptés on compte 30 propositions
de bois c'est totalement inédit
sur les dérives des influenceurs chers
Stéphane sur le permis de conduire
chasse achat sur les RER métropolitains
cher Jean-Marc ch cher David ou encore
sur les délégations d'actes aux
soignants non médecins chers Stéphanie
se sont vos idées qui nous permettent
d'avancer vous êtes à l'initiative j'ai
besoin que vous le restiez et avec
l'appui de France je souhaite que mon
gouvernement s'appuie encore davantage
sur vos travaux
et je partage bien sûr chère Sylvain
cheriel ce que vous avez dit sur
l'importance de renforcer encore le
travail transpartisan c'est comme ça que
nous faciliterons l'élaboration des
majorités lors de l'examen alors
vraiment merci pour tout le travail
accompli merci pour votre implication et
pour votre ténacité au côté du
gouvernement pour porter le projet du
président de la République
dans tous les moments même les plus
difficiles nous sommes restés unis
toute l'histoire de la Cinquième
République la montrée la division est un
poison elle mène au blocage des
institutions à la paralysie politique
puis à la défaite lors des élections
depuis plus de six ans la force de la
majorité c'est son unité c'est grâce à
elle que nous parvenons à réformer c'est
grâce à elle que nous sommes crédibles
devant les Français c'est grâce à elle
que nous tenons face aux oppositions
c'est grâce à elle que nous maintenons
le cap fixé par le président de la
République
alors bien sûr l'unité ça n'est pas la
négation des sensibilités ça ne veut pas
dire empêcher le débat bien au contraire
nous devons avoir des moments d'échange
et une fois que notre ligne est fixée
avancez en bloc c'est le dépassement
porté par Emmanuel Macron depuis 2016
c'est la condition de notre réussite au
service des Français
depuis un an malgré le contexte de
majorité relative nous avons surmonté
des épreuves ensemble alors j'ai
confiance ensemble à nouveau nous
pouvons tout réussir
cher Aurore pendant plus d'un an tu as
fait vivre le groupe Renaissance avec
courage et avec passion pour tout ce que
tu as accompli un grand merci
[Applaudissements]
aujourd'hui chers Sylvain tu as pris le
relais et je sais que tu es déterminé à
animer ce beau collectif à porter nos
combats et nos idées dans les mois qui
viennent
déterminer à donner sa place à chacun à
préserver notre unité et à avancer avec
nos alliés du MoDem et d'horizon
mes chers amis nous vivons dans une
société où la violence est de plus en
plus désinhibée et les émeutes de cet
été en sont un nouveau symptôme
face à ce constat nous avons plus que
jamais une responsabilité celle de
préserver notre cohésion nationale
nous devons rassembler trouver des
solutions pour améliorer le quotidien
des Français
réaffirmer avec fermeté l'autorité et le
respect des règles et apaiser notre pays
faire nation au-delà des clivages c'est
le sens des rencontres de Saint-Denis à
l'initiative du Président de la
République avec les chefs de parties
représentés au Parlement
il s'agit de montrer à nos concitoyens
que nous sommes capables de nous
retrouver sur des sujets clés
aujourd'hui le vrai clivage c'est bien
entre ceux qui veulent améliorer le
quotidien des Français et son prêt à
travailler ensemble et ceux qui
exploitent la brutalisation de la
société soit en soufflant sur les
braises soit en désignant des boucs
émissaires
dans ce contexte oui le dépassement est
plus que jamais d'actualité
alors unis avec nos partenaires du MoDem
et d'horizon nous sommes déterminés à
agir
mes chers amis dans quelques jours une
nouvelle session parlementaire va
commencer
nous continuerons à avancer sur nos
priorités pour répondre aux attentes des
Français
pour continuer à faire baisser le
chômage et atteindre le plein emploi
vous examinerez le projet de loi qui
créera France travail
pour notre transition écologique vous
avez terminé l'examen du projet de loi
industriel verte pour veiller à l'ordre
républicain vous finirez l'examen des
textes justice qui permettront notamment
la création de 10000 postes
supplémentaires d'ici 2027
avec le projet de loi numérique nous
allons faire en sorte que ce qui est
interdit dans l'espace physique ne
souhaite également dans l'espace
numérique
et avec le projet de loi immigration
nous porterons des mesures efficaces et
un texte équilibré un texte capable de
rassembler une majorité à l'Assemblée
nationale comme au Sénat je sais que
Gérald du travail avec beaucoup d'entre
vous et il a toute ma confiance pour y
parvenir
bien sûr très vite les textes financiers
vont nous occuper
de nouveau chers Stéphanie cher
Jean-René vous serez en première ligne
aujourd'hui nous résultats économiques
sont bons la France est attractive notre
croissance tient alors même que beaucoup
de nos voisins européens sont entrés en
récession la politique de l'offre montre
ses résultats 2 millions d'emplois ont
été créés des
usines qui ouvrent alors nous continuons
on ne change pas une politique qui
marche nous gardons le cap pas de hausse
d'impôts nous gardons le cap avec des
investissements massifs partout c'est
nécessaire
ce budget c'est une meilleure
reconnaissance du travail de nuit à
l'hôpital chers Aurélien ce sont des
meilleurs salaires pour les enseignants
ce sont des policiers et des gendarmes
supplémentaires dans vos
circonscriptions ce sont 7 milliards
d'euros en plus pour la transition
écologique
enfin ce budget c'est celui de la
responsabilité
après plusieurs années de dépenses
exceptionnelle de crise il s'agit
désormais de revenir progressivement à
la normale et de ramener la France sous
les 3% de déficit d'ici 2027
si nous y parvenons c'est notamment
grâce aux dizaines de milliards d'euros
d'économies permise par nos réformes en
particulier celle de l'assurance chômage
et des retraites
à la veille du débat budgétaire nous
sommes lucides
votez un budget marque l'appartenance à
une majorité
nous aurons donc probablement recours à
plusieurs 49-3 pour permettre l'adoption
de nos textes financiers
comme l'an dernier certains crieront au
déni de démocratie
mais ne laissons pas dire n'importe quoi
c'est parce que le blocage et le pire
des périls démocratiques que les auteurs
de la Constitution ont conçu et écrit
cet article
alors comme des majorités de droite et
de gauche avant nous comme nous l'avons
fait l'an dernier nous ne laisserons pas
la France sans budget
bien sûr
[Applaudissements]
bien sûr nous travaillerons jusqu'à la
dernière minute pour trouver des points
de convergence et enrichir le texte
notamment grâce à vos propositions
vous me connaissez je ne recule jamais
devant mes responsabilités si je
n'utilise pas le 49-3 de gaieté de cœur
je refuse plus encore l'immobilisme
[Applaudissements]
enfin dans les mois qui viennent nous
devrons engager des chantiers majeurs
sur lesquels vos idées seront
essentielles
parce que nous sommes déterminés à
réussir la transition écologique avec le
président de la République nous
présenterons bientôt notre planification
écologique aux Français et dès la
semaine prochaine j'échangerai avec les
chefs de partie et les membres du CNR
pour partager notre vision d'une
écologie ambitieuse porteuse de
solutions
parce que les violences de cet été
imposent des réponses fortes et globales
je présiderai en octobre un comité
interministériel à la ville
parce que les temps partiels subis ne
permettent pas de s'en sortir parce
qu'il est insupportable que certains
métiers essentiels comme les aides à
domicile ou les agents d'entretien
soient encore si mal payés parce qu'il
est inacceptable que certains soient
condamnés à passer toute leur carrière
au SMIC à la demande du Président de la
République je lancerai le mois prochain
une conférence sociale pour répondre à
ces défis
[Applaudissements]
et parce que le harcèlement frappe
encore trop d'élèves de l'école jusqu'à
la maison et qu'il conduit parfois au
pire comme nous l'avons vu tragiquement
encore la semaine dernière je
présenterai prochainement un plan
complet contre le harcèlement sur chacun
de ces sujets vous avez tout votre rôle
à jouer j'ai besoin de vos idées et de
vos propositions
besoin de vous pour faire aboutir la
proposition de loi sur l'accès aux soins
besoin de vous sur la proposition de loi
bien vieillir que nous examinerons au
plus vite besoin de vous pour alimenter
nos réflexions et bâtir un texte sur le
logement
je vous l'ai dit il y a un instant et je
le répète place à l'initiative
parlementaire
[Applaudissements]
mes chers amis pour conclure mon propos
je voulais évoquer avec vous deux
échéances électorales importantes
la première dans 10 jours ce sont les
élections sénatoriales
chers-françois je te remercie pour le
travail que tu mènes au Sénat ou tu
portes nos combats nos valeurs et nos
projets avec tous les membres du groupe
RDPI je veux dire mon soutien à tous nos
candidats qui mènent une campagne une
campagne intense sur le terrain auprès
des élus locaux
la seconde échéance électorale dans
quelques mois ce sont les élections
européennes
en 5 ans notamment grâce à l'action du
Président de la République et avec le
soutien de nos députés européens menés
par Stéphane l'Europe a changé face à la
pandémie pour la relance économique face
à l'agression russe en Ukraine à 27 nous
avons trouvé des solutions
bien sûr tout n'est pas parfait bien sûr
des lourdeurs persistent bien sûr les
défis restent immenses mais nous
pourrions tout perdre car l'extrême
droite veut remettre en cause les
traités et menace la construction
européenne et n'oublions jamais que
derrière le rassemblement national il y
a la Ligue du Nord rue Sophie et
anti-avortement il y a l'AFD allemande
climato-sceptique et adepte de la
théorie du Grand remplacement il y a le
PVV néerlandais ouvertement islamophobe
et dans le leader voulait quittez
l'Union voilà les alliés du
rassemblement national voilà ceux avec
qui il veut gouverner l'Europe
[Applaudissements]
la bataille qui s'annonce c'est un
combat pour l'avenir de l'Europe mais
c'est aussi un combat pour nos valeurs
et nous allons le mener avec nos alliés
de la majorité l'Europe et notre ADN et
nous sommes les seuls à être clairement
pro-européens
ce combat est d'autant plus important
que partout sur le continent les
populistes progressent voire accèdent au
pouvoir
ces élections européennes sont capitales
sur le chemin de 2027 et je le dis pour
ces élections comme pour tous les
scrutins il n'y a pas de fatalité à la
victoire de l'extrême droite nous allons
nous retrousser les manches et combattre
l'extrême droite à chaque occasion nous
ne lâcherons rien
[Applaudissements]
partout soyons à l'écoute de nos
concitoyens répondant à leurs
inquiétudes et à leur préoccupations
tordons le coup aux contre-vérités des
populistes qui accâbleront l'Europe et
en feront la responsable de tous nos
mots au contraire montrons que les
solutions passent par l'Europe je compte
sur vous pour porter ce combat dans vos
circonscriptions
[Applaudissements]
mes chers amis l'année qui s'ouvre sera
riche nous avons des défis à relever des
réponses à apporter il y aura des
difficultés et des obstacles c'est vrai
mais unis et rassemblés nous
parviendrons à les surmonter les
Françaises et les Français exigent des
réponses nous sommes prêts à leur donner
près avec tous les parlementaires de la
majorité prêt avec tous ceux qui veulent
que la France avance je compte sur vous
vous pouvez compter sur moi et sur tout
mon gouvernement je vous remercie